I feel like we're living paycheck to
paycheck and I'm always confused that a
family with a gross annual income of
over 250,000 it feels like we're just
getting by my husband and I have been
together for 14 years and married for
nine and we've always sort of kept their
finances separate yeah I I think you
need to sit down with him and say Hey
you know we've done it this way 14 years
it's passable but I feel like I'm
holding this together I feel like I got
all 10 fingers stuck in the Dyke and
it's I'm and it still feels like water's
getting over me and I really want to
combine these things so that I don't
mind doing the execution of our plan but
I'm tired of developing the plan by
myself and I want us to combine things
and you and I make a a group of basic
decisions on what we're going to do with
our money lay out a budget each month uh
where we know where every dollar is
going to go we both agree to it and then
I'll do the execution